this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman from Paul
Reubens to Paul McCartney he was in
Florida this week and he ended up giving
a lecture at a place called Rollins
College last Thursday they had a lottery
for their students there and it was in
their music department and if you won
the lottery you got to sit in on a
songwriting class by Paul McCartney
that'd be pretty cool if you were a kid
studying music right he said here's what
he said in the class look I don't know
how to do this well thank you very much
Paul McCartney why am I wasting my time
in this classroom every time I approach
a song there are no rules sometimes the
music comes first sometimes the words
and if you're lucky it all comes
together if you're not lucky you get let
him in remember that song you wrote yeah
you don't like that
Kevin someone's knocking at the door
someone's ringing the bell someone's
knocking at the door someone's ringing
the bell do me a favor open the door and
let him in that was a [ __ ] song but
by a mental deficient that was a song
not everything he writes is let it be or
yesterday I don't know it's a fun song
it's it's dumb
it wasn't Paul McCartney we older we all
would have said that's [ __ ] horrible
oh it's easily singable as a kid I loved
that song when I was a kid have you
heard his new song about meat-free
Monday no you know he's a vegetarian
yeah and so he's trying to push this
idea mate free Monday where no one eats
meat on Monday so being Paul McCartney
genius songwriter he is he wrote a theme
song for meat free Monday would you like
to hear a little meat free Monday yeah
he's not kidding this is an actual
[ __ ] song okay that he released Paul
McCartney the guy was in the Beatles he
wrote this song can we play that
meat-free Mondays
[Music]
alright sit the [ __ ] down fall you're
done you're finished now me free Monday
it's a fun day I have a four and a half
year old she could write those lyrics
even the animals are like ignore that
please eat yeah see this take us out of
our misery
[Music]
you
[Music]